have you ever wished you could be part
of the audience when we film LED live
well you're about ready to get your
chance we're doing a live event at the
College Dale Community Church in College
Dale Tennessee August 17 6: through 10
p.m. the purpose of this event is
twofold first we want to give back many
people have reached out to us and told
us they appreciate the ministry and led
live in particular in some cases it has
become part of their lives and something
they look forward to everywh week we
want to give you the opportunity to
share that experience with a friend in
person second in 15 years of ministry we
have never really made our needs known
we are growing and for us to push the
boundaries of what is possible in
Ministry it's going to take time work
and money we're going to share those
needs with you and invite you to partner
with us unscripted videos are fun but
our LD live show on YouTube is edited in
advance uh so we can't really interact
with you but we can at our LA live show
at our live event so come and ask us
questions and you know we'd love to hear
from you you've heard us talking about
documentaries and sharing resources and
t-shirts these will all be available
after the live event one more thing
backstage passes are available as part
of our fundraising now remember the
event itself is free registration is
free and everyone needs a ticket to get
in but for those who would want
backstage access that is available for
purchase today using the link on your
screen warning this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children viewer discretion is
[Music]
advised what's up everyone welcome back
to El live and today we are discussing
the Paris 2024 Olympics Ceremony now you
might have heard it all but we are going
to behind the scenes of what this all
means behind the dark origins of this
Olympic God's Feast that was being
portrayed and I'm telling you you're
going to learn something new today and
it's going to shock you and hopefully it
will be of value to you so anybody
watched Olympics Ceremony I know you did
part of it right yeah I I watched it uh
probably for the first hour hour and a
half yeah anybody else I was actually
outside doing something and I walked in
and I had some family in town and so
they were all watching the opening
ceremony and I walked in just at the
tail end of this thing and I remember
just being like what is this wow well I
left right before it I didn't know what
happened the next day didn't fry your
brain NOP wow yes same I didn't know I
saw the media uproar after the fact and
like the pictures and all that me too I
wasn't really interested in watching it
but um you know the picture we all
probably saw was this one at the top
where a lot of Christians were upset
because they said there were trans and
lgbtq people and uh drag queens uh
pretending to be part of the Lord's uh
Last Supper which is a painting by
Leonardo DaVinci so this is what upset a
lot of people and so this was the
beginning of it of this scene here and
then this guy came out so he's getting
put down on like a platter or something
does anybody know who this guy actually
represents that is not Sushi By the
way Smurf yeah hor Smurf you know we did
a show on on Blue so whenever I see
people painted up in blue it's pretty
interesting to kind of recognize real
quick there's a lot of different
cultures that have blue people that are
usually like demons and stuff right like
you see it an avatar you see it in
Aladdin and uh yeah a lot of different
ones oh and then yeah the Hindu gods are
all you know the blue ones and and
there's some pretty like racy ones where
they're like doing X-Men X-Men Scott
blue yeah Smurfs yeah for being
familyfriendly right yeah yeah and they
got children as well on on the side
there they
got yeah yeah and shades someone was
letting me know that the purpose of this
was so that anyone watching would be
able to identify with someone on screen
did you guys hear that yeah it was all
inclusive that's what I heard yeah I
don't know if it's that inclusive though
for children or for uh you know people
of different religions and it's
interesting that you know Paris and
France are so like secular but then
these are Olympic gods that is a
religion that's being portrayed here
right and if it's all inclusive you know
I mean it's like I guess include the
people that would make fun of
Christianity I mean it says that but it
didn't start that way and I'm sure Den
you going to get into that the origins
of the Olympics so they could see all
they want but there's there's a purpose
here yeah so then we also have this
image here this is a transwoman or drag
queen who was uh walking on this table
that was used for the last supper and
they had like a catwalk fashion show
with these you know people in this lgbtq
community uh right before the the last
supper was held allegedly yes allegedly
I mean like here at the at the Paris
Olympic not uh when Jesus was around um
so this is the guy who is behind uh the
whole design I guess of the whole um
Paris Olympics uh opening ceremony his
name is thas Jolie I guess is how you
pronounce it in France uh this is in the
rap it says the ceremony was designed by
Jolie the french actor and director who
was appointed artistic director of
Ceremonies in 2022 quote for Paris 2024
appointing Tom Thomas joli as artistic
director of the ceremonies is an
ambitious choice that is consistent with
our vision with his impressive career
Tom Tomas joli is at the Forefront of
the young creative and ambitious French
artistic scene explained Tony eston
eston president of Paris 20124 at the
time his extraordinary shows are proof
that he knows how to break norms and
take them to the next level and then
this is what he says toas Shi um there's
Diana arriving on a table why is he
there first and foremost because he is
the god of celebration in Greek
mythology and the Tableau is called
festivity Jolie said translated to
English Okay so that's a Greek god the
blue guy he's talking about the blue guy
yeah he's a Greek god so the Greek god
is the god of celebration in Greek
mythology and he is arriving on this
table that looks like the Last Supper
mhm that's right well yeah is in
response with Christian outrage saying
that it looked like the last supper and
tamas is like no that's not actually the
case that was not my inspiration at all
or the painting from well who paint
Leonard Da Vinci yes that that was not
his inspiration it was actually this
Greek god it just happen to be uh in the
same assembly as the painting what do
you mean I mean like there's the same
sort of characters in the same positions
of like the pain similar yeah but it
just happened to be it's it's kind of
like Evolution right you just kind of
mix up the bag and you throw it together
and it looks like that right yeah he's
also the god of wine which is also one
of the Jews of France and the father of
Zana the goddess of the river San the
idea was to depict a big Pagan
celebration linked to the gods of
Olympus and thus the Olympics so I find
it interesting obviously he's saying
like well we just want to have a big
Pagan celebration which in and of itself
is kind of like uh yikes but also this
is the god of wine right and if this was
portrayed um as the Lord's Last Supper
then what comes down at this place it's
uh a God that represents wine what was
being drunk what at the Lord's Last
Supper yeah the wine representing the
blood of Jesus and you know being
covering the the the the sins and it's
interesting that Revelation has the end
of the world a cup of wine that is
really like making all nations drunk
right with this like false Doctrine so
interesting yes so it it really it seems
to be like they're saying um get lost
you God of the Christians I I'm I don't
want the blood of Jesus I don't want the
wine instead we want this God of rry and
wine and all this other stuff and
feasting and and that kind of wine it's
I'm not saying that's what they're doing
I'm saying it's an interesting contrast
an interesting concept given that he
does say in a later quote that I'll show
you that it was inspired among other
things by Leonardo da Vinci's painting
well and given the history of the the
French Revolution and what that really
meant for God right we don't need God
we'd rather have reason than God um so
it's kind of interesting to see this
many years down the road that sort of um
Spirit if you would you know what I mean
being still brought to the table no pun
intended wow drop that
one all right so here is the man himself
again sitting here as the blue man again
of resus so it might look a little bit
funny but I want to make sure it was a
decent quality now um let's talk at
dionysis uh his name is diis
utherus and he's also known as The
Liberator and uh
bakus um he's the god of wine making
fertility festivity Insanity ritual
Madness religious ecstasy and theater
his name is also the Liberator
interesting okay a couple things right
here I just wanted to point out that you
capitalize the word God because it's the
beginning of a sentence not necessarily
meaning the God so the reason why he's
known as bakas by the Greeks is because
uh for a frenzy he is set to induce
called
Baka and as the Liberator his wine music
and ecstatic Dance free his followers
from self-conscious fear and care and
subvert the oppressive restraints of the
powerful his theis or thyis a fenel
stemmed scepter sometimes wound with Ivy
and dripping with honey it's both a
beneficient wand and a weapon used to
destroy those who oppose his cult and
the freedoms he repr presents those who
partake of his Mysteries are believed to
become possessed and empowered by the
God himself well doesn't that just sound
like the devil y I mean he's going to
destroy you and they call it a cult and
it's all about rry and it that's that's
fascinating and why do you want to
include that in a in an opening ceremony
to the whole world the whole world is
watching about literally replicating the
idea the iconic idea of Jesus going to
the Cross to save Humanity like it's so
opposite because it's in their history
what are the Olympics about are you
going to get to that I want to go ahead
of you no no go for it how it started
the Olympics is literally a pagan
Festival to the god Zeus so this is an
offbrand for the for the whole thing is
it more blatant nowadays sure but if you
know the you know and that this is this
is my unpopular opinion so to speak
about outrage you will judged outside of
this table yeah
exactly in the comment section however
paganism is inir conflict with
Christianity so I understand the offense
and the outrage it should be there as
Christians we are called to live a
certain way and share the love of Jesus
and call Sin by its rightful name sure
when it comes to the Olympics which
started has its history in paganism it
has its history in being a festival
towards a pagan God then we have the
director paying homage to a Greek Pagan
God so he says I didn't see that that
quote where he switched up so I'm
looking forward to seeing that um then
Christians being offended in this
context is bizarre to me because it's as
if it's as if I am a vegan for Spiritual
reasons and then I go to a meeting at a
slaughterhouse and I'm offended by what
I see yeah because I should know the
context why am I shocked at what's
happening here why are you slaughtering
pigs don't you know that it's offensive
to me as a vegan it's like I don't get
it so yes I I understand that outage in
its general form but in this context of
the Olympics why are Christians who
should be knowledgeable sit down and
observe this thing and be shocked by the
paganism that's all around when this is
literally what the Olympics is all about
that's a valid point I mean it's a it's
a point worthy of mentioning for sure
wow interesting drop the hammer one
thing though that I find
absolutely unfortunate I'll put it this
way is uh our leader response to it did
you see Jill Jill Biden's reaction she
was there she attended the Olympics and
afterward at a press conference she
called it spectacular it was spectacular
the rain did not dampen our spirits and
Casey honestly every step of the way I
was thinking to myself oh my God oh my
God how are we going to Top This how are
we going to top this so okay so Paris
has the you know Eiffel Tower but we
have
Hollywood and and right and the magic of
Hollywood that makes all dreams come
true so I think we're going to be okay
now she's a self self-identify Catholic
right wow so husb that's one thing it's
one thing to to be blunt leave paganism
let them let them do what they do it's
another thing as a Christian or a
believer in God to see that and say
that's spectacular
yeah I think that's the other side of
the spectrum of like just taking it in
and and it reminds me of the three
reasons why people leave the Christian
church it's indifference it's satanic
deceptions and it's and the pressure of
circumstances and when I'm thinking
about the satanic deception side of
things Satan always goes for the person
with the most influence or is in a
position of influence so someone like
Joe Biden who's a Christian saying
something like look at this Pagan
display is spectacular I believe is a
form of satanic deception to deceive
Christians all around to accept this as
oh this is great stuff yes yes it's
really unfortunate but but here's here's
where I'm going to give you a tiny
little bit of push back in this world of
inclusion is that's what they're I think
they're trying to do right they're
trying to be very inclusive with adding
all these details in there it's like the
very very group that is probably the
most vocal with hey you've offended me
because of your Christian beliefs or
whatever like this would turn around and
do this to another group like that to me
is like but why would you do that if
that's your one main thing it seems like
you would be the most sympathetic
towards not offending other people for
the sake of offending other people you
know it's like don't be offensive just
for the sake of being offensive and then
wave your flag don't be offensive to me
that doesn't make any sense at all to me
in the world stage and this being a
world stage seems rather purposeful
seems like the
I I have a really hard time believing
that people would be like oh uh sorry we
didn't know I mean how many committees
did this pass through how many people
sat around and went this is a great idea
let's do that you know what I mean like
it's like it can't it can't be that you
didn't know that this was going to
happen and like well we didn't mean to
be offensive really yeah you're in the
center of Europe where a lot of these
like art pieces reside M to to this
dionis I think it's interesting that
he's the god of theater mhm and he's
being put on display in this way in this
theater context good point all eyes on
him I mean oh it's like we're taking
part in this ritual this Festival yeah
do do you think though in in a weird way
like they are just trying to build a
divide like absolutely yeah like it like
like it's playing the hegelianism right
it's really putting this group against
this group and then let them Fester with
each other and then we'll provide some
other sort of and that is completely I I
believe that's what they're doing
because that sets you up for the beast
power to come in and the mark of the
beast to being pushed because the beast
power coming in as a peacemaker should
be like well I'll make sure to unite
everybody under one rulership so to
speak so that you can get the mark of
the beast pushed but you have to have
chaos first and that's what's happening
all over the world right now and people
are I mean you just you just look
through YouTube like people are
generally really offended by this right
you're seeing a lot of people be vocally
setting forth forward like you know go
watch the soccer game
tonight I mean it's true yes I know
you're making a good point how far does
your rage go you're making a good point
how many Christians are boycotting this
yeah you're making a good point you know
all right so moving on so dionysus's
parents surprisingly not surprisingly
are Zeus and S so let's take a look at
Zeus Zeus is the god of thunder
lightning rain and wind remember Luke
10:18 it says and I saw Satan fall like
lightning from
Heaven according to
study.com Zeus's name comes from the
Latin word Deuce which means God now the
Slavic root word Joe means to shine
which reminds me of the Lucifer being a
lightbearer and it also shares roots
with the Proto Indian European God deuse
the god of the sky or skyf father and
interesting that the Bible describes
Satan as the prince of the air right
exactly so there's a lot of similarities
there that uh people generally speaking
recognize now here's his mother uh in
Greek mythology s was a mortal get this
Mortal unmarried princess she was
seduced by Zeus who had disguised
himself as
Immortal uh the what story does this
remind you of from the the Bible who was
uh who was um deceived by another
creature who disguised himself Satan
exactly Garden of Eden with Eve um so
she got pregnant by Zeus and had
dionysis after she died now s means
mother of the earth just like Eve was
the first woman who was ever created and
S was was she she died because uh I
guess the wife of Zeus found out that he
was cheating on her and killed s but
then she was later on raised Back to
Life by her son dionysis and uh she
became a goddess just like Satan told
Eve that she would become like God you
know if you eat of the fruit um so
interesting that there's a lot of
similarities there yeah that is
interesting that you know the original
lie that was told to humanity you just
see this like lie like repackaged and
sort of handed to different cultures but
you can see the ACT original lie still
embedded into this lie yeah absolutely
and so when you think about this what
does that make dionysis it makes him the
son of Lucifer right oh interesting
isn't that crazy instead of the Son of
God like instead of the promised one
that's coming right it's like the pretty
much the sort of the anti- version of T
version yeah the Twisted version of that
because again like he and we see it
right here uh for the festivities
segment Thomas Jolie took inspiration
from Leonardo da Vinci's famous painting
to create the setting producer said in
the statement clear says clearly there
was never an intention to show
disrespect toward any religious group or
beliefs jie is not the first artist to
make reference to what is a world famous
work of art from Andy warhole to warhole
to The Simpsons many have done it before
him but so he's saying or the producers
are saying yeah he did take inspiration
from this so now we have this painting
that depicts uh the original painting
depicts Jesus with the Lord's Supper but
then here in its dead we have this
Olympic God come in its place that we
can literally see is the son of Satan of
Lucifer who is the god of wine and Ry so
instead of saying well it points to the
wine as like jesus' blood and redemption
and forgiveness of sins it's an opposite
of that of this satanic partying rry
with wine and so and anybody who says
something or goes against this God he
says I'm just going to destroy you and
he's considered the Liberator I'm going
to set you guys free through my parties
and revering and everything
worldliness and if you don't follow me
well you're destroyed that's literally
like the the the you know of Satan yeah
absolutely that's it that could be his
like tagline yeah I mean that's crazy
yeah that is crazy actually but to ky's
point it is really interesting that this
is them heralding their own kind but he
he said he was trying to be inclusive
and and and celebrate diversity and all
that which I still think it's
interesting that he chose this way right
yes it is telling the story but it is
close enough that people mix it up and
that's why everyone is heated it up but
um you guys might have heard about um
for the for the sport of Surfing there's
this guy in Brazil because I'm you know
I'm keeping up with everything Brazilian
right nice and there's this Surfer
called xang shanka and he was going to
represent Brazil in the Olympics for
surfing and when you think of America to
a symbol to represent America you might
think of an eagle you might think of the
Statue of Liberty you know right um in
Brazil we have the statue of the Christ
the
Redeemer right and he had that on his
surfboard and he was asked to remove it
because it was Christ a religious figure
and they couldn't they couldn't have
that because they were trying to be
neutral with everything no come on they
so much for inclusivity I know true yeah
and and it's like he he posted on his um
on his Instagram two weeks before the
Olympics happened he's like yeah I can't
have it even though this this is like
what symbolizes Brazil you either choose
a soccer ball or Christ the Redeemer
right and it's it's just a statute to
represent a country not really well well
I think that's a even dou um interesting
when looking at Japan's outfits um I
noticed lots of dragons that they had on
their if that was a symbol that
symbolizes their country I mean that is
fascinating that they would say you
can't have that but you can put a dragon
on you or you can have Christ the
Redeemer on a surfboard but you can have
something similar enough to Christ on
the opening ceremony yeah even if it is
or if it's not so like I see your point
candy it might have not been MH Christ
or the Last Supper but it was still a
religious figure enough that like even
just a symbol of it wasn't allowed for
other people but they tried to do it so
is Zeus not a religious figure or were
dianis or whoever that was that they
were def oh no that's not a God here's
the thing that I want to say though I I
disagree with being offensive in general
okay so let's just say like there were
some Christians that were dressing up as
drag queens and they were saying you're
going to burn in hell and there the the
whole ceremony has to do with like you
know haha look at these guys they are
not going to make it to heaven right I
would have just as much problem of a
Christian doing that and I would say
that's not okay you're making fun of
humanity don't do that right but why why
is why is they why are they not
recognizing this and they're coming out
saying you're right don't do this that's
a bad thing I mean seriously I would
expect Christians to call out other
Christians if you're being hry mhm M
where's the people that are in this
lifestyle that are saying you know what
you're making fun of somebody I disagree
with that they should be coming to the
Forefront and talking about that I agree
so here is the image again just for as a
reminder of what it looks like and
Thomas Jolie the artistic director
behind the flamboyant opening ceremony
said the scene had not been inspired by
their last supper and depicted a pagan
Feast linked to the god gods of Olympus
that's interesting that is interesting I
was like I'm going to look into this
what is that this is a Dutch art and
architecture historicist uh Walter
schonenberg now for those Walter
schonenberg I am Dutch so I can I can
read this trust me nice so I will
translate directly to as to what it says
um he's saying uh at the opening
ceremony of Paris 2 24 there was a
tableau uh a live painting shown of the
Feast of the Gods uh of the painter yon
Von berer in 1635 which is kept in the
museum Dijon Apollo the son God is
notice noticeable by by the crown with
the Rays of light and bakus who is bakus
dius is other name for for uh um bosis
uh he has the grapes on his head
so this is the painting right here what
do you guys see I see a goat
man that's oh where I mean the half goat
bottoms with the
wow did not notice that that's Pagan
right off the bat you you remember it
was in um it was in chronic ofn
Chronicles of Narnia it was Mr tness who
so what does it mean pan pan was the
greatek god of uh a sort of deviant and
sexual rape and torture and you know
yeah so there's also a bunch of naked
people look at what I'm about to
highlight yep Angels but that's children
oh that's babies what are they what are
they
called yeah I always thought this was
weird in art anyway um Valentine what is
it what are the
B yeah so that's babies right now this
is a uh clearly a painting of uh the
Feast of the Gods uh we see dionysis
there enjoying his grapes and they're
having alcohol they're drinking they're
feasting they're reing there's nakedness
and nudity and there's children now look
at this
[Music]
joining the Rivalry yeah honestly um I
think any any normal um Christian parent
would would why do we have to keep
asking that question when it comes to
Pride
parades like why are the children yeah I
don't want to generalize but when it
comes to any uh significant event where
where pride is being displayed why do we
keep having to ask that question why are
kids involved why are kids here because
I think that the the general idea is
that kids are not ready for certain
types of life when I ask that's like
that's problematic why do we even have
to ask that question why are they there
type of a thing like I think the world
is trying to be part of the like remove
them world I I think they're adding this
into the equation though man and as much
as the LGBT community does not want to
address this children is the next
Frontier yeah children are yeah this is
where they are going with this they are
dropping the age of accountability and
whatever you know it's it's coming and
and I was on on Twitter because that's
where you get all the commentary right
on Twitter you can see people defending
this it's like oh no it's should be
there yeah like oh you know it's just
because your definition of sex sexuality
and and diversity in America is
different from Europe um in Europe it's
art wow it's art to have especially
theen naked people just look at the old
paintings and whatever it's like you're
just too Americanized the West culture
is different my my husband said I I
cannot verify cuz did not see this but
basically said
someone's parts were hanging out I saw
that unfortunately during the so you saw
it I saw that so during the ceremony I
saw there was a um a a a gentleman that
picked up the child and was dancing with
the child and people were commenting on
that and saying like why is this person
like you know dancing I mean dancing is
an act of it was a sensual dance Mercy
Mercy Merc the whole thing is Central
though whole is Central I know it's
touching me in the first place you know
even it's just a square like you're
adding alcohol and children and rry and
but just for me just to think like
literally
someone's parts are hanging out uh with
a child present is bizarre to me okay so
we we deal with this in this country all
the time with the drag queen thing that
is being displayed in front of children
and everything's hanging out there too
yes and lots of parents like like I
would have a problem if a female dancer
was wearing a g string and doing those
kind of things in front of my children
at a at a public library I would have a
problem with that but but the fact that
it's a male and it's in this particular
setting it's like people feel
discriminated against and it's like but
but but but that's that's inappropriate
on every level like go go to your corner
if people want to come then to each
their own but here it was like to the
whole world broadcast sat satellite to
every country and stuff like that so
it's like s and gomorra man Jesus is
coming soon that's right so the Olympic
Committee did Apologize uh let's see
what the communications director has to
say clearly there was never an intention
uh to to show disrespect to any
religious group on the contrary I think
that to me Le really try to
really intend to to celebrate Community
tolerance that was his word yesterday
and uh looking at the result of the
polls that we shared uh we believe that
this ambition was uh was achieved if
people have taken any offense uh we are
of course really really sorry
Sol
[Music]
all the ideas that he just listed that's
the most abstract I've ever seen them
they were hard to detect but it is
actually really what he is coing Con
convey right they have in their country
the right to believe what you want to
love what you want right so if there's
children there is there a
line I mean this is the line that art
has always pushed up against right art
actually changes the popular opinions
that's what the definition of art really
was designed I mean when Comics first
came out it wasn't just hey we want to
make fun of people they were politically
making fun of people in the Renaissance
Era and they were changing the public
opinion of politicians because they were
making fun of them or putting them in
bad lights right and so they have
constantly always used art to break down
the status quo MH yeah it's interesting
Christianity has been a major part of
French history there there were
historical uh displays there was a
French Revolution right and and other
pieces of French history so how much of
Christianity was predominant here or was
it you know just paganism and it was
like you were saying candy earlier is
like yeah they're showing the history
the the Greek history the Olympic
history through Greece and stuff and
then they're making the French stuff in
the middle right they had they had like
uh some people will also talk not only
about the the Last Supper but also about
um the horse of the Apocalypse that came
in yeah thought that they thought was
the horse of apocal they thought it was
but they're like oh no it's just j a
dark entering question I wonder why they
wouldn't admit it be like oh yeah that's
the that's the Christian representation
that's the horse you know and I didn't
see this part but people are saying that
there was also a segment where they
worshiped a golden calf as well I didn't
see that but saying that was part of it
there was the Last Supper the the horse
of the of Revelation I mean if we're
going to hit apostasy let's just let's
just throw it all in there I know I know
but it's like well I thought we were
supposed to only talk about the Greek
side but now we're including It Through
The Eyes of France yeah France and so
you talked a little bit earlier about
some of the French history that was
included in the ceremony let's take a
quick look at that so do you guys
remember this part of the ceremony oh I
saw that live yep so this is Madame
Marie antoanet she was the last queen of
France and during the French Revolution
she was beheaded in
1793 and her head is singing The
Aristocrats will hang them wow so d
right after this there is this French
metal band playing goira and they sing a
song from The Revolution uh sa which
means it will be fine so this was
actually a song that was sung During the
Revolution that they turned into a heavy
metal song uh also interesting uh for
those who don't know in 1798 the pope
was removed from office as well and the
Vatican was no longer the head
overseeing the um politics and kings and
Nations right because the pope was at
that time above Kings and Nations which
was a good thing separation of church
and state which causes freedom of
religion so there were some good things
that happened in the French Revolution
the French Revolution saw a period of De
christianization where revolutionary
leaders saw reduce the influence of the
Catholic church and promote secularism
churches were closed or repurposed and
religious symbols were removed as part
of this this secularization The Cult of
reason was established it was an
atheistic belief system intended to
replace Christianity with a new form of
Civic worship based on enlightenment now
check this out do you guys recognize
what this portrays what this is when it
comes to the cult of reason
this is the goddess of reason they took
a woman a a real woman and they parade
her through the streets culminating in a
ceremony of at Notre Dame where she was
enthroned and celebrated the festival
included music speeches and theatrical
performances promoting rationalism and
the rejection of religious Superstition
you see what's under under her feet
Jesus it's the cross she's stepping on
on the cross yes so this was being
portrayed at the Olympics as the opening
ceremony and so I'm thinking wow they I
mean the French are obviously proud of
their history but you can see how
secular the nation is now again the good
thing that came about it was the
separation of church and state but they
completely took away all um you know
like wealthy people the the queen was
being murdered for my understanding For
No Good Reason um and they took away
Christianity and said we're going to be
atheists now it's basically what they
were saying and what's really sad is
what they were Waring against was a
wrong picture of Christianity this is
how the devil loves to work right he
twists and taints and and perverts to
the point where people get sick of that
version and then they're like we don't
want anything to do with that we want to
go over here and and and and have
nothing to do with that what there we
were we they were rejecting was a
perverted gospel basically yeah pretty
much yeah that that is not a real rep
representation of Jesus Jesus dying on
the
cross they took that symbol right there
and turned it into a a absolute mockery
of what God really stands for yeah so so
again this is being portrayed at the
Olympics where they're saying like this
is our history the French Revolution do
away with all Christianity and uh and
take on worship the goddess of reason
and and and become part of the cult of
reason but then they portray this like
Olympic God that is all about rry and
sex and and drunkenness and just do what
thou will and if you don't agree with
our cult we're going to have a problem
we're going to have a problem with you
and and we're replacing Jesus as the
Savior for like this figure that in
Greek mythology is like the son of Satan
I mean come on yeah that's they're
making a statement as a nation this is
what we're going to do if you don't like
it get lost yeah bet you didn't know
that when you were watching the opening
ceremony and it's interesting that they
keep showing like I'm going to call it
uh um knockoffs of of actual history
like like the um the history with the
Greek mythology or whatever we can see
that it all points back to you know
stuff that happened with Jesus or Heaven
and Earth like Zeus and is like we can
see uh how it can relate to who Satan is
or stuff like that all the connection
but if you show it you know multiple
times you show it enough
times Jesus becomes a knockoff virsion
of you know the Greek mythology or
whatever mythology true right so if you
keep showing it over and over again then
when people look at Christianity we are
the ones that are cop copying or trying
to be copycats or trying to you know be
our own version of the Greek gods or
whatever right right so that there's
also this aspect of of the danger of
showing this history over and over again
right and and mocking Christianity
because is like oh yeah we're just
mocking you know the the knockoff
version of us it's true yeah so flee and
I were talking about this like why Snoop
Dog so if you think about all that we
just explained right like the doing with
Christianity being okay with the
profanity and the Ry and the feasting
and the
sexuality you know that's true that's
really what he stands for you're almost
heralding the American version God of
that yes because what does he promote in
his music and videos drugs sex
prostitutes do whatever you want to do
look for the money and and the fame and
not for Christianity whatsoever and he's
carrying it the interesting that it's
like we have these like sort of
mythologically ised versions of these
stories but then here's a real world
example yeah for you to follow much and
people worship him I mean they do wow
they do so lastly let's look at a couple
of Bible verses second Peter 33 and four
knowing this first uh that scoffers will
come in the last days walking according
to their own lusts and saying where is
the promise of his coming for since the
fathers fell asleep all things continue
as they were from the beginning of
creation uh Matthew 24:
37-39 but ask the days of Noah were so
also will the coming of the son of man
be for as in the days before the flood
they were eating and drinking marrying
and giving in marriage until that day
that Noah entered the Ark and did not
know until the flood came and took them
all away so also will be the coming of
the son of man you know if we are really
truly living in the days of Noah how did
Noah respond but he was a pray PR he was
a preacher till the day he walked into
that Ark and tell that shut right he was
making a call for righteousness he was a
preacher of righteousness and um I no
doubt he had a love for the people I
mean you can't do that day in and day
out and not have a love for those people
yeah like we how should we respond like
should we be upset like no let's stick
it back to them or whatever like that or
really honestly should we be responding
like Jesus responded when people
persecuted him right Lord forgive them
they don't know what they're doing they
don't know what they're saying they
don't know what they're even promoting
by by literally heralding the son of
Satan right these are people that we
potentially could live for an eternity
with yeah we should be praying for them
and there's the verse also I don't know
if you're going to show that verse but
Jesus does say you're going to be hated
and persecuted for that's right that's
true but I overcame the world so don't
worry about it that's right that's right
it does appeal to it is like you know
there's respecting your God they're
disrespecting your religion all of that
it ju it does feel like you know you got
to go out and fight for it right like
Christians are typically seen as weak
and they're making a call for like
people to stand up like if you're
religion is that true why don't you
fight for it where's the protest all
that what they said to Jesus when he was
on the cross if you're really the son of
God come off the cross Jesus like my
kingdom is not of this world I'm dying
for you that's my battle and Peter
represented that when he was like let's
go to battle right and he slices the
guy's ear off right and Jesus is like no
no no no that's not how this should be
done in fact putting the ear of the guy
back on really shows you Jesus's
character right God said vengeance is
mine yeah let let him be the one that
that does that and people are saying
that God did intervene because it was a
power outage during the the Olympics oh
wow and the only place that there was
light was a church wow like pictur that
I did see pictures that like during the
Olympics everything went out off and
there was only the one light up on the
hill and you can see it sh statement
right so it's like even if it was just
Greek mythology or whatever if it wasn't
a direct walk up you know yeah
Christians or people from other
religions are seeing this and like well
maybe it did offend God a little right
yeah yeah yeah let's look at this last
verse Luke 1728 through3 likewise as it
was also in the days of lot they ate
they drank they bought they sold they
planted they built but on the day that
lot went out of Sodom it rained fire and
brimstone from heaven and destroyed them
all even so it will be in the days when
the son of man is revealed I'm not
sharing this because we're preachers of
like Hellfire and brimstone and we're
just God's going to come from you what
happened right before this Abraham was
saying to God lord if it's only like
this few people in the city they're
righteous would you not destroy the city
God said yes what about just this few
people he's got said yes what about this
number yes Lord don't be mad at me five
and it's not because Abraham is better
than God God wanted to have that
interaction with Abraham to show his
goodness that he he wants to save the
Bible says God is mighty to save right
he desires to save us John 3:16 know for
God so loved the world that he gave his
only begotten son that soever believes
in Him should not perish but have
everlasting life that's why I'm showing
this because we are in the last days
this is happening right now we just saw
at the Olympics another fulfillment of
Sodom and Gomorrah and it's only going
to get worse but God is a god of love
and he's saying I will forgive you I
want you to come to me please I long for
a relationship with you and think of the
few people that God was willing to stay
back his his judgment upon that City for
those people be the people that stays
back God's judgment on that City you
know what I mean like are we calling
down fire from heaven being like no burn
them look at what they did like fry
these guys dis said and Jesus said no
yeah no no no no pray for these people
even when they spit and they spitefully
are offending you and and and they're
offended by you and your just stance for
Christianity or whatever like we know
these times are coming like this but but
be that voice that is like Lord forgive
them yeah they don't know what they're
doing they don't know what they're doing
Steven said the same thing yeah you know
and he was being stoned as well amen so
it's not something that only Jesus could
endure because Jesus was Jesus right
like no Stephen did the same right you
know Peter changed he was Christians
taking out Christians or like people
that thought they were following God you
know what I mean like like be careful
you know calling down judgment you might
be fighting on the wrong side yeah or
Moses right like don't kill the people
right or if you're going to do that then
take my name out of the book yeah right
standing in the Gap y you know for those
at home if you listen to this and you
feel a calling on your heart I'm
encouraging you to seek the Lord while
he may be found
because what happened at the cross you
know Jesus got scorched literally hooks
being put into his back and his skin and
his tissue his muscle being pulled off
he got it wasn't just whipping it was
scourging
scourging he got spit on he got a crown
of thorns being pushed into his head and
then they nailed him to the Cross which
was one of the most incredibly painful
ways that the Romans could torture
anybody where you would have to push
your whole body up against the won and
your hands and your feet just to take a
breath otherwise you would
suffocate but that wasn't the worst of
it Jesus died having everybody's sins
put on him and he felt like he was
separated from God he did that for you
and no matter what you've done no matter
what your background is he's saying I
died for you and I want a relationship
with you and I want to cleanse you from
all your sin and I want to forgive you
and give you a new life eternal life in
heaven that is beyond our
imagination so if you're feeling a call
in your heart I encourage
you pray to God ask him can you reveal
yourself to me if you're real show
yourself to me if you're seeing what's
happening in the world and you're
recognizing that there is a great battle
between good and evil happening where
Christianity gets attacked over and over
again that maybe this is evidence for
there being a God go and pray and ask
the Lord show yourself to me I've done
it I know everybody at this table has
done it for to ask the Lord show
yourself to me and uh we found something
that nothing else can fill only God can
fill that hole in our heart and only he
is called the Prince of Peace who gives
us peace that nothing of this world can
ever give us so thank you guys so much
for tuning in if you were inspired by
this video please drop a like uh leave a
comment make sure you hit subscribe and
we'll be back here with LED live next
[Music]
week do you have questions about the
Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your
journey created you
Jacob and he you form you
Israel I will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God and he shall go no more
I will on him the name of my
[Applause]
[Music]
God alone but by every word of that
proceeds from the mouth of God
[Music]
I'm sorry do we know each other it seems
like maybe we've met before I don't know
this is uh it's awkward though just as
much for me as it is for you I really
wish I had a conversation
[Music]
starter oh hey oh what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]